signori siamo al terzo episodio con quel
bellimbusto di pietro è mio amico
fidatissimo con il quale prosegue senza
problemi
in questo minecraft harcourt comunque vi
lascio al video perché anche questa
volta un po di cose sono successe e
dovete vederle poi è difficile trovare
dove andare figure qua qua qua qua
atestina a non avevo visto neanche per
sbaglio infatti l'ho visto tubo mari in
due strade di san lorenzo ma dico
esattamente sarà sbagliata proseguo
anch'io però dal produttore
no meno male che lo fai in momenti in
cui siamo qua a volte mikali sulla
questo questo non sly in questo guarda
quanto lo so sto gioco bravissimo nella
loro mica visto che adesso sul pezzo di
terra di destra ok ok ora vai avanti di
ok un oggetto per effetto stata in tour
aspetto di terra sempre sulla terra
allora ok adesso saltato guarda mai sul
pezzo di legno hai citato un pezzo
allucinante lo re
questo pezzo in legno hai fatto un chip
ma me lo voglio prima tu mi hai detto di
fare questo
noi dice di fare il giro a ok il
creatore del gioco è subdolo che ci
parla cioè stupido non a segrate
bravissimo però se l'è dimenticato
eccoli solo applicando sono bravo
abbiamo quello grazie grazie
in atto questo consiglio perché avrei
saputo proprio come continuare ma già
sotto fai schifo
vergognati che ne so però non se non
puoi fare così così non lo so
sì puoi farlo l'ho fatto fare se anche
bacheca cose l'unica favara sono giu ok
ora sono nella lava senza però morire
come hai fatto tu adesso davanti ai miei
occhi
qui l'ho fatto neppure quanto me chiaro
no
ok ok ok sono stato bravissimo fatto
delle cose incredibili
tutto giusto ma alberi no ciao ciao
amico ho sbagliato l'ultimo all'ultimo
salto sbagliato che pirla ha forse di
mira da colpi in basso capito sì
esattamente
ora devi cadere di qua o andare avanti
di qua mi sa che devi in ogni modo se
cadi cadi torno prima allora ho capito
di fare così guarda così sull'albero e
poi vai sul finale mi sei piaciuto un
botto in questo anch'io mi piacciono le
sue porte
grazie vai amigos sono cascato questo
livello lo abbiamo fatto anche me lo
ricordo è molto meno si sa che c'erano
gli serva stride con le zucche e
remember harem and all the plans spetta
poi c'è lo slime soft acqua cioè ti pare
ma per ora no ok perfetto a me o floor e
lo stiamo facendo benissimo stato
proprio bravo vieni a perché io non ho
capita infatti infatti dicevo si stava
girando mi sono accorto che sempre più
bravo per un attimo avuto l'impressione
di essere tornati dietro il 26 livelli
ok basta ho detto bob cui lapis e kick
lapislazzuli anche diamanti oro e
lapislazzuli sono quelli che hanno il
tiberio buono morto scambierò no no no
no cosa succede all'inizio ok no che
riportano che toshiba insieme tre
livelli indietro così cattivo da fatto
prima con la lava soprattutto no sono
caduto all'ultimo salto che pirla ok ok
a questa è la porzione della piccola che
effetto come hai fatto con ascom fare
cose allora sia sì cosa no non è ora che
non devi andare qua perché è invece se
ti fa male la mano a teneva faresti
salti te lo giuro ma fanno nel miglio lo
percorrerete fuori controllo
esatto in un tunnel carpale andiamo
avanti guarda c'è una mano rossissima al
ed era lì ho l'età
no no no ok il meglio che piange poetici
diverse limi aspettando che lo faccia io
sapevo fare sta roba schifoso a misano
aspetta ma mi sa che devo andare qui
sopra e allora devi andare qua ecco solo
passano qua
avanti allora c'è un coso dove devi
saltare sopra mi sono spiegato benissimo
non sapeva piegarvi il meglio di così
poca devo fare no non è vero non è vero
non è che allora aspetta aspetta aspetta
sono bravissimo vieni vieni ad ali ciao
pietro
bello attendo qua sei anni ok ci sono
sei i mici sono mi stavo gustando
fortissima no no è che già dopo è
partito non mi piaccio questo e ghiaccio
quello più scure sempre ghiaccio scusami
o scudetto scusami
scusami ho capito con la scure sempre
ghiaccio si è sempre i viaggi con
l'oscuro ho capito e sono veramente
nelle persone molto cattive
my dad tu hai fatto parte solito si ma
non sto capendo dove vi aiuta mi vieni
qui vieni perfetto bravo qua è motivo è
perché non capisco meno bisogno del tuo
aiuto
bisogna detto tutto solo quando non
capisco a quale trovate ritrovato cosa
ha scritto mi dici siamo ripassati
all'inizio no è vero che siamo due
hai ragione hai ragione hai ragione sai
che non avevo via pensavo fosse il pezzo
dell'inizio quello io mancano visto
invece figurt insomma che è pirla io
l'avevo visto mi ha detto il bagno non
sara lee colori dove siamo arrivati
bravo pietro mi piace mi sia piaciuto
non so dire cosa non so ma paolo non far
male fa bravissimo giusto
sono stati bravissimi no sono caduto che
vi ha sicuramente giuro arrivare dietro
ok ok con un arrivo ricadute julie
andata bene che non sei corso di tanto
no
ok anche momento pensavo fosse l'inizio
di 19 se tocchi l'acqua di teletrasporta
l'iniziativa se lei veramente provato
sei pazzo e per la shin valore per
lasciare la demenza questo veramente
pazzo e vai
bene qua immagino che poteva fare così
il mio amico adesso si radica di quattro
temi seguito si sta diventando sempre
più difficile capire dove andare ad
esatto esatto
ok di qua giusta è sicuro che si vedono
però vabbè loren lorenzo è sbagliato
perché si voglia di cui credo che si sa
pochissimo e sto andando in altre parti
no anche questo è pagato niente raga
saltiamo quando ci sia livelli così
purtroppo dobbiamo saltarlo peccato
perché sta roba non funziona di centrare
il buco
questa è una cosa un po complicato
aspetta porca vacca volevo farti o
centrare veramente nero era erano buoni
tensione mia è più o meno spetta
esattamente nei punti no ha tra l'altro
se che al di sotto di farti tutta
un'altra strada per salire wow wow il
suo livello siamo veramente capaci
entrambi vivono drummer sono speed
runner high street runner
no sono già tutto essere caduta chiedo
siamo blade runner nel blind blind
runner the maze runner perché ho la
forza mamma ma guarda che mi si
bloccherà solo l'incredibile è la terza
volta che smette di questa che c'è a noi
invece non c'era un blocco che ce l'ho
fatta ma come non era più difficile
non so perché sono caduto 20 volte
esatto vieni bravo bravo o demonio vieni
qua molto bene molto bene molto bene
molto bene profitto tutto un fenomeno
già no no hay piano con l'arabo
devo rifare di nuovo sotto con lo slime
billy perfetto livello 36 amici
ah ok ce l'ho fatta si si ogni tanto
perché qua io mi sto già mi sono
preparato psicologia apostolo no però ok
ho preparato psicologicamente per un'ora
e ho perso e tu che sei arrivato adesso
c'è proprio una volta si è riuscita ok
poi zitto zitto di vista mi piace quando
parlo e si avverano le cose ok ok
perché io per noi sempre lalia ne sono
sicuro che non devo entrare da qua non
si sa infatti se c'è qualcosa dietro ok
ora per distrarmi la casetta 6 ma era
per distratti la casetta perfetto è
morto ok qua io non ho capito cosa di
fare gol
ora se puoi fare questa cosa che sto
facendo che faccio sempre per credo di
sì perché se non capisco usa mettono a
fare sti cose bene ma a ok guarda non
sono sicuro se invece tanta tanta tanta
sembra di essere stati taranta pietro
bond ciao io sono perché c'è un timer
sta crescendo l'acqua a legna adesso
capiamo 1
devi correre corri corri corri corri
amico ma senza di me dopo mio dirlo ma
ora l'acqua e lo spendono solo d'andata
e non si ferma non si fa non si fa non
si fermano si però sonoro è
difficilissimo è immaginare questo è un
bel livello che sei veramente bene non
difficile vai
mamma mia che lento che lento che lento
che lento gli stock acantho sotto vai
veloce soprattutto perché sono scarse le
10 sono veramente scarso cosa succede
mai
scegli subito mi sono già buttato scusa
mi dimentico del water rising militato
li mette a fissarla perché non capisco
se sei sale o meno invece sale sempre
barca vacca 6 vivo e acqua acida che
come la tocchi mori è proprio così fatta
cioè quasi fatta ciò così cartacea così
fatta guardo alla mia ora quali tanto
egitto ora cadi mammamia questo sarà
bravo aiuto ma tu mato mato mamma mia
che dribbling cristiano cosa è un
coniglio le piume ciò cos'è sta roba io
trovare salta come santon erba sinistra
o quale erba quell'alto l'ora e guarda
con attenzione di nuovo ad avere quei
pezzi di harmony ho capito mar coniglio
mila persone ancora in coniglio e poi
saltare un botto come se le nostre euro
perché non mi mettere ansia per favorire
gli edifici
ma tu che kakà cosa devo fare qua
sinistra risaltare salt russa comunque
roba lì non è vero sono caduto ad uno
folk e difficili ma allora lo re da
giovedì dopo giallo si salti sull'erba e
smettila di far partire la prima per chi
l'ha fatto bene sei ore per fare questo
salto di fatto no perché ancora sta
salendo la
ce l'ho fatta dai non ci credo solo
fatto incredibile non ci credo sia
perfetto per effetto aiuto ci sono sono
forte advanced mad mad water champion
grazie grazie mille e se vi sia piaciuto
non mi piace ci vediamo poi con un
prossimo bisogno di ma incappa corto da
qualche giorno per gli piace la serie a
me sta facendo tanto tranne pietro che i
ragazzi il video piaciuto come noi ci
vediamo
eh sì
proprio così
[Musica]